let's see what's happening on the phones
today six one seven eight three zero
forty seven fifty is the number let's go
to our caller from the six two six area
code go ahead I yeah hey David I was
wondering if you could help me
understand why progressives want minimum
wage to be fifteen I live in California
and when minimum wage went from eight to
ten like prices skyrocketed and I have a
lot of friends their own small
businesses and a lot of them had to like
how their business or went bankrupt so
someone had to sell their business
because the the minimum wage went from
eight to ten dollars
yeah like didn't have enough money to
pay their employees anymore who was that
like well I mean I have one friend in
particular that that happened to what
kind of business was it it was a
restaurant okay and so what happened was
that when the wages went up from eight
to ten the the restaurant wasn't a good
business anymore and he sold it yeah
exactly
but it was still a good enough business
for someone else to buy it right so like
someone said oh this is a good business
I'm gonna buy it well I mean he helped
it like he just like um I guess he got
kicked out cuz you stopped paying so did
he sell the business or was he evicted
from the from the restaurant yeah he was
Invicta actually oh so he didn't sell
the business at all no okay all right
well listen it it's not clear sounds so
so let's see I guess I'm not even sure
where to go with this one what evidence
do so let's talk about the price
increase part you mentioned what in what
way did you notice that the price is
increased when the minimum wage went up
well I mean I was just a kid so like I
would go to like like burger stands near
my house and then when it was five bucks
who went to like eight bucks so the
burger went from five bucks to eight
bucks yeah alright listen I mean I don't
know that this is the right time to get
into a full discussion of the minimum
wage but I'm not sure that your
recollection here is exactly what I
would maybe base policy decisions on but
generally speaking
there is an equilibrium wage and you
know $200 an hour wouldn't be that wage
so like raising the minimum wage to $200
an hour would be bad for the economy but
$15 an hour is actually lower than the
inflation adjusted wage dating back to
1968 so there's a case to be made that
that that's relatively uncontroversial
but you know I'm sorry for your friend
that got evicted and yeah I mean I'm not
sure what else to say but I do
appreciate the call